you both play these incredible women who
go up against the system to bring this
story to light Kira is it helpful to
have like a whole body of written work
by a person to be able to bring that
person to the screen yeah definitely it
is I mean it was a it's been it was a
great privilege to to learn about and
Play Loretta McLachlan she was an
amazing journalist
um I did read a lot of her work which
was very helpful it's very evocative uh
it has a definite Spirit to it which was
uh helpful in playing her there were
also interviews uh with her so actually
there was a great one where she was
where she was literally talking about
the case which was very helpful
um she had a kind of Steely
determination which uh which I loved
um so so yeah it was a great privilege
but you know there is a point where you
go this is also a fiction it's based on
a reality but it's not a documentary so
you know you have to kind of take it and
and run with your own ideas as well um
and that's always the joy of doing
anything like this
yeah Harry in an age of like True Crime
podcasts and documentaries all about
serial killers that we've got at our
fingertips all the time it's interesting
in the context of like the time of this
film to see that when it comes to
exploring the darker side of human
nature we haven't really changed all
that much why do you think that is
well I do think that adage which is
attributed to Margaret Atwood is true
um uh men are afraid women are going to
humiliate them and women are afraid men
are going to kill us and so I do think
that a lot of women are really obsessed
with crime because
um frankly there's a real physical
disparity and we we live under Threat
all the time and as we know from Other
Stories being told right now if these
women who had been murdered in Boston
were women of color the story wouldn't
have been in the newspaper at all
and so we still have a long way to go
when it comes to um really um
investigating women's concerns and
looking out for their safety and these
women were at their time really um
really indefatigable this was a very
challenging job for them uh everybody
thought it was a stunt job right that it
was um basically stunt casting for
journalism that they were just putting
women in front and center as like a cute
uh way into a salacious story when in
fact they were really serious
journalists and um the only thing they
could do was put their heads down and
work really hard and uh unfortunately
that's that's still true especially for
women of color they have to be 50 better
than anybody else doing their job to get
recognition and um that's why I think
this story is really important because
there are so many ways in which it's not
that different
yeah Kira when it comes to the case of
the Boston Strangler what are your
thoughts on
do you think it was one person do you
think it was several people copycats or
working together I don't think it was
all one person I I I'm only basing that
on on exactly the same information that
everybody else has got so I I know that
you know that that but but no I I think
it was probably multiple people
um
uh thank you so much for your time it's
been an absolute pleasure having this
conversation with you both all the best
thank you
story is about
then who investigated these crimes more
so than about the crimes or the
criminals themselves is that part of
what Drew you to this what means you
want to be part of this project it
really it really was because
um I you know the character of Jack
McLean who who is the newspaper editor
for the uh record American where these
two women journalists work
um is interesting in in his own there
are some side stories about what's going
on politically uh with the news
newspaper but but
specifically
these women journalists working in the
early 60s
it's it's a great reminder of how
difficult these times were for women in
the business they were they were not
given the respect that was due them and
I had an acquaintance acquaintance with
a Pulitzer Prize winner
and uh who's in the business who worked
at the Boston Globe newspaper and
she directed me to
just the books exactly the books that I
needed about the politics in The
Newsroom the hierarchy what's going on
and how competitive and tough it was
before computers
early 60s a lot of leg work a lot of
knocking on the doors to get interviews
it was uh and especially being a woman
The Newsroom was very dismissive to them
and they had to prove themselves time
and time and time again and I wanted to
be a part of that story yes
this is an interesting uh through a line
in this too about the relationship
between the police and the newspaper and
not wanting to ruffle feathers is that
something that you were kind of aware of
for a women well like what surprised you
about it yeah I was very naive I was
very naive and that's that's the
pleasure that's half the fun of you know
taking these roles and and learning and
doing your research and it's like it's
like going back to school you get these
great history lessons and and and
you you think you you have the idea of
how things were but then you realize
like we said you know
62 that was a completely different era
completely different time you know and
only recently concerning the women
journalists
you know things started to change for
the better when I'm talking to Eileen my
friend uh uh she said it only got better
in the in about the mid 80s did things
start to improve for women
is there a phrase that you would use to
perfectly find that Boston accent every
time is there a way to get into that
particularly
oh man uh that's a good question I uh
yeah I guess there are a few but uh they
involve words that that can't be
repeated on television so
I have to leave it up to your
imagination
[Laughter]
this particular case has been
fascinating to people for decades and
you know given the evidence that we have
available and the story presented in
your film what do you think is the truth
behind who who did this you think it was
one person you think was a number of
people
I mean we'll never know I guess but it
it it everything points to the
fact I mean to the to the possibility
that there were probably multiple
perpetrators
um
because I'm pretty sure even uh
desalvo's DNA didn't match up with a
couple of the murders and so uh it's
almost impossible that that they were
all him
um so yeah I mean that's part of this
the you know
the fascination of this particular film
is that uh you know the uncertainty
about the resolution of the actual true
life crime and and the fact that uh
there's still some kind of
um
confusion about it is
disturbing and and so to understand why
that is and how the police were were
willing to to settle on one guy when in
fact that probably wasn't the real story
uh is really part of the driving force
certainly of my character's narrative in
the in the movie because I play somebody
who's a police detective who's just
disgusted with the way that the
investigation's been run and and feels
that forensic psychology which at the
time in this in the 1960s was was really
brand new and making huge strides but
the the police department was very
traditional minded in the way that they
were going about their investigations
and this one in particular and weren't
interested in kind of profiling this guy
uh psychologically and and that was
driving my character completely nuts
which is why I started leaking
information to to this journalist
you know you just talked about why this
particular case has been fascinating
that the fact that you know we still
don't really have answers I might never
have answers yeah but in general I mean
like this was a sensation when the story
was being written by Loretta and the and
and today we're all listening to True
Crime podcasts and watching
documentaries what is it about this dark
side of human nature that makes people
want to tune in
well I mean the the potential for human
beings to do these extreme things that
you know uh acts of violence betrayals
uh you know all of the the part of our
behavior that
we you know we would like to pretend is
is not uh that we are none of us are
capable of is always just fascinating
because because normal everyday people
uh you know do not I mean you know do
these extreme things in their lives and
it's been the source of of uh drama from
the earliest ancient you know ancient
Greece you know people who murder their
own children or I mean it's it's always
been kind of confounding to people and
that that that that kind of thing can
happen and yet also I think everybody
recognizes God there but for the grace
of God go I I mean there's only you know
a thin line between
um you know someone's life just turning
completely upside down and and you know
the tenuous hold that you have on some
kind of normalcy in your own life and so
uh I think that's just always been
dramatically fascinating like
psychologically what goes on to sort of
uh allow your your brain to just
completely
shift into some kind of lunacy it's it's
it's hard to imagine and yet not that
hard to imagine
yeah no I feel you Alessandro uh
congrats again on the film man thank you
so much for the time hey you too take
care